So, the best trading platform 100%
depends on what kind of trader you are
and somewhat of what you're looking for.
And so, in this video, I'm going to give
you a run through of what I would
consider to be the best one for stocks,
options, futures, forex, and crypto.
Now, first off, Ninja Trader. This is a
platform I've used for over five or six
years at this point, and they've
recently started that I don't know if a
lot of platforms do this. They started
having contests where you can make real
money from demo trading. So you can as a
beginning trader can go in, join a
contest that usually are, you know, just
a couple of days, so they're pretty
quick and you can earn real money. Some
of these prize pools can be $25,000,
$50,000, and I'm pretty sure they have
some that are up to $250,000.
So, this is some serious potential to
make money as a beginning trader just
while you're learning and practicing
without taking the risk of putting real
money on the line. Now, in terms of the
actual platform, cuz that's the most
important part. I always found that
their charting was really, really clean.
And as a futures trader, the execution
and ability to take trades and manage
trades was really, really easy. They
have a ton of third-party add-ons that
you can either buy or install for free
that make it really, really robust and
customizable and as well as you can
pretty much connect any broker to it and
trade a lot of other assets. Generally,
Ninja Trader is focused on futures as a
charting platform, but you can also a
lot of the time trade forex and crypto
and other assets on it. I always keep my
trading super simple and clean, and
Ninja Trader is really nice for that,
for just entering in trades at a click
of a button, but also being able to
calculate how much I'm going to make or
lose on a specific trade with custom
tools. Now, just like pretty much every
platform these days, they have demo
trading. They have the ability to run
back and simulated trade old data, which
is really good as beginner for learning.
Ninja Trader, I would say, shines as a
desktop platform. They do have a
web-based platform, which makes it
really, really good for just accessing
everywhere. If you don't want to
download a whole desktop version, I
would say in general, desktop platforms
are way more powerful if you're serious
about trading than trading on a
web-based system. And just like any
platform that we're going to go over, I
would say there's always a steep
learning curve to them. They all are
slightly different which is kind of
frustrating but generally you know after
about a week and you know one tutorial
video on YouTube you'll have it figured
out and you'll be able to consistently
trade with how you want look at charts
and analyze them. Now if you're more
interested in options trading the best
option for that is Thinker Swim. I used
to trade options before I switched to
futures and Thinkorswim was what I used
all the time. They have insane tools for
analyzing and looking at option spreads
and being able to see how they're going
to play out, what it means for your
option spread or trade or contract when
it gets to a certain price. And as well,
just the options chain on there is super
clean. I always found that trading on
Thinker Swim was the best way to go for
options. Another option that is actually
really good for beginners with options
because when I first started out,
options are insanely complicated once
you kind of understand them. Honestly,
they're still kind of complicated with
some of them. That's why I honestly
switched to futures. Just trading them
was complex. Either way, another really
good option for it, which I thought was
simpler than Thinkorswim. Thinker Swim
is the end all of really good options
trading of it has everything you want
once you understand it all it's great
but when you're first starting out it's
a lot and so I would recommend checking
out Tasty Trade their platform is kind
of designed in a lot more visually
pleasing and visually easy way to
understand options and how the spreads
and everything works and so that even if
you're demo trading and Just checking it
out and practicing is really what I
would recommend for options. And then
once you kind of have it figured out,
start to mess around and play with Think
or Swim and go from there. Now, let's
talk about Forex. I've actually traded
Forex on Ninja Trader. And I thought
just because I really like that platform
for futures and trading on, you know, a
smaller time frame chart, like a minute
chart or a five-minute chart, I thought
Ninja Trader worked really well for
Forex. And so I definitely recommend
checking it out if you're looking to
trade forex. But to give you another
option, TWWS is a really good robust
option kind of like Thinker Swim in
terms of its functionality for trading
forex. Now the problem kind of like with
Thinker Swim is it's very complex
looking. I've tried to use it before and
as a beginner it was very confusing. And
so if you're more experienced and like
the more complex, more robust platforms,
I would definitely check TWWs out. It's
very fast. It's again, it's a desktop
platform which is really good for fast
trading and entering in quickly.
Sometimes if you're trading on web
platforms like Trading View, it can be
slower. There can be internet issues.
There can be problems. Not that it
happens very often, but it can happen
more often than a more dedicated
platform. I would say if you're going
for a more beginnerfriendly and a very
popular option, nothing wrong with this
option at all. Tons of people use it.
Trading View is probably one of the most
popular platforms to use Forex on. And
I'm going to lump crypto in with this as
well because you can access pretty much
anything on it for your charting and
trading. You can demo trade on it. It's
super easy to access because it is a
web-based platform. And so, as a
beginner, if you're just trying to get
your foot in the door, kind of just
check things out, it's a really good
option to trade forex or crypto on. If
you're looking to just kind of wet your
feet, look at charts while you're
watching and learning YouTube videos.
Just like any other platform, it has
your indicators, your drawing tools,
onchart trade management, and it allows
you to, you know, access that pretty
much anywhere from, you know, a laptop
and just be on a web browser. I'm not a
huge fan of the mobile app, but it does
still work if you're looking to trade on
your phone as well. Again, across the
board, I would not recommend trading on
the phone. It's just generally not a
good idea if you're trading something
that's more fast-paced. Now, if you're
trading something that's longer term,
swing trading and stock trading, trading
on the phone can be fine because you
don't have to be really, really
fast-paced. You know, the chart's not
moving fast on a daily chart. Now, just
to run through a couple of other
options, Trad Station is a good trading
platform. It's a lot more algorithm
based, but you can trade options,
futures, and it's kind of like Think or
Swim. You can trade a lot of things on
it. But from what I understand and
remember about it is it does have some
paid features versus some of these other
free platforms. But if that's what
you're looking for, more robust.
Sometimes paid features when you really
get into trading can really be worth it.
when you're risking, you know, $500 on a
trade at some point, paying $100 for an
extra feature one time doesn't seem like
a big deal, but that's definitely down
the road once you kind of know what
you're doing. So, I'll leave links to
all these down below. Again, I highly
recommend Ninja Trader with those
competitions that they have if you're
kind of not really sure what you want to
do. Easy way to get some money and start
trading. And also, if you choose to go
with Ninja Trader, I have a tutorial on
the web-based platform and the desktop
platform you can check out right here.